people over the way that children
brought here illegally are treated once
they're in custody
you haven't heard a lot of concern about
that recently and maybe you should
tonight migrant facilities at the u.s
border are now at
730 percent capacity
are reports of children going without
showers or beds julia rosas is a senior
writer with townhall.com he's
in nearby mcallen texas near the mexican
border and joins us tonight with an
update
julio thanks so much for coming on what
is i know there's been a massive influx
into the united states what what are the
border detention facilities look like
tonight
well unfortunately the not not too good
and the reason why
just as you mentioned before they are
way over capacity
and that is just simply due to the
massive numbers of illegal immigrants
that are coming across
uh in sectors like the rio grande valley
on friday night i counted 263 illegal
immigrants
crossing the rio grande and turning
themselves into border patrol and
spent about three hours sunday night it
was about 239
again the same crossing the rio grande
and hand themselves over to border
patrol
and the reason why is because they knew
they weren't going to be deported right
away
because either they were a family unit
or they were unaccompanied minors some
as young as eight
and so right now we're seeing the
consequence of the influx because
of we there's an administration in place
that not only has open border rhetoric
but also open border policies in place
we just showed tape of a woman also in
the state of texas an elderly woman
being thrown to the ground in a bank of
america
franchise because she wasn't wearing a
mask do you know anything about the
covet screening
that the byte administration is doing of
the people coming into our country
illegally
so kova tests are being administered in
cities like brownsville
and again i can tell you uh just
anecdotally
hearing the people that were coming
across in the groups there was a lot of
coughing there was a lot of sneezing and
whether or not it was coveted
obviously remains to be seen just
because obviously they're exposing
themselves to the elements on this long
and very dangerous journey
right and so uh there's just a lot of
abuses
uh that happen here and so it's just a
very dangerous uh journey for people to
take and unfortunately we're seeing
kids who are by themselves uh taking a
taking taking that journey
yeah a lot of them julia rose's force at
the border tonight thank you so much
immigration into this country illegally
has exploded tomorrow we're going to
visit one of the sources of it one of
the most dangerous places on earth we'll
be broadcasting from there
tomorrow night we'll hope you'll join